et c'est vous t'étiana au garcova
bonjour journaliste responsable du
département international à
l'ukraine-crazis Media Center vous
intervenez depuis Kiev merci de nous
consacrer du temps en cette nouvelle
journée de bombardement alors avant de
revenir à ce cette réunion d'urgence des
pays membres du G7 un mot peut-être de
la situation
acquiev on a entendu ce matin les
sirènes de nouveau retentir où en
êtes-vous précisément au moment où l'on
se parle oui tout à fait les sirènes en
déclenché à 8h du matin exactement comme
hier donc on s'attendait à une frappe
massive contre toutes les villes y
compris qui vivent où je me trouve je me
trouve dans la mallio de qui Yves donc
les sirènes étaient comme ça en alarme
jusqu'à 13h ça veut dire 5 heures
d'affilée une chose inouïe pour pour qui
enfin en tout cas depuis plusieurs mois
on avait plus on avait bien sûr des
sirènes parfois à plusieurs fois par
jour mais normalement ça devrait 30
minutes ou 40 minutes ça change tout
comme ça dure pendant 5 heures ça veut
dire que l'école est annulée déjà les
coller Annuler pour jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine les gens essaient de ne pas
sortir puisque on a bien vu comment
c'est risqué avec les attaques contre le
centre de la ville de qui hier
heureusement aujourd'hui nous avons rien
entendu sauf le travail de de force
aérienne
ukrainienne dans certains quartiers les
gens rapportent d'avoir entendu le
travail de de ceux qui protège notre
ciel tant qu'ils le peuvent finalement
qui n'est pas touché aujourd'hui il y a
quelques accidents dans la région mais
rien on est sûr et confirmé à cet
instant malheureusement la ville de le
vivre a connu quelques frappes et mais
la journée les victimes n'ont pas été
confirmées donc on espère que en termes
de vie humaine en tout cas cette journée
est moins sanglante heureusement pour
l'Ukraine que c'est le d'hier on imagine
l'inquiétude suscitée par cet état
d'alerte permanent
une question de votre état d'esprit à
vous et puis des Ukrainiens plus plus
généralement on en a vu certains dire et
bien qu'on continue à vivre à faire à
faire avec quel est votre état d'esprit
aujourd'hui
bien sûr qu'on prend des alertes
aériennes au sérieux maintenant depuis
hier parce que c'est vrai parce que
avant pendant des longues mois c'était
ça faisait partie de notre quotidien
mais à vrai dire à plusieurs gens je
veux pas dire les ignorer mais continue
à faire ce qu'on devait faire moi
personnellement y compris aujourd'hui on
fait plus attention parce qu'avec les
alertes qui durent ça commence à être
inquiétant voir à boisson puisqu'on sait
très bien que avec une attaque massive
c'est-à-dire quand il y a plusieurs
missiles qui arrivent en même temps un
autre défense aérienne et
malheureusement insuffisante pour les
abattre tout donc hier nous avons vu que
à peu près 50% du missiles russes
envoyer ici ont été abattus mais le
reste est arrivé ici donc ça veut dire
la moitié c'est beaucoup c'est toujours
trop et bien sûr les conséquences sont
graves aussi en termes de infrastructure
d'électricité nous avons eu beaucoup de
coupures vraiment beaucoup de coupures
hier et même aujourd'hui il y a pas
d'eau courante d'un appartement je me
trouve tout simplement parce que il y a
le manque d'électricité pour toute la
ville donc ça ça change le quotidien
mais en même temps je pense que la
guerre a commencé à faire partie de
notre quotidien il n'y a pas de panique
il y a pas véritablement de peur on
regrette que la vie bien sûr échanger
d'une manière opère aussi facilement ce
qu'on appelle la civilisation mais à la
fois il y a toujours cette résolution de
country parce que malheureusement on
nous a pas donné le choix il faut que le
Ken résiste parce que sinon si on
résiste plus on y sera plus est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment malgré tout qu'on
est passé à une à une autre étape que
les Russes ont franchi encore un pas de
plus en bombardant au massivement
l'intégralité du pays un concentrant
plus seulement l'effort sur l'est de
l'Ukraine que votre vie est peut-être
plus menacée qu'il y a de jours
oui en fait ça ça ressemble à un certain
escalade de la part de la Russie même si
on n'aime pas trop le mot escalade ici
en Ukraine parce que on a déjà vu
énormément de choses avec des des
victimes civiles avec des missiles qui
arrivent vers les immeubles ou quand les
gens dorment comme par exemple la
vaporidia plusieurs jours d'affilée donc
ça fait ça fait toujours des morts mais
c'est vrai que ça change
psychologiquement et on comprend que le
tactique de la Russie est justement de
d'intimider des frayer des terroriser la
population donc c'est leur dernière
chance en fait parce que on sait aussi
que leur arsenal de missile n'est pas
illimité donc il faudra s'arrêter à un
moment ou l'autre selon vous justement
ça c'est une vraie question pardon c'est
un peu la tentative de la dernière
chance aujourd'hui on fait usage
Vladimir Poutine
oui ça ressemble vraiment à un geste
désespoir en cul de coco et ils font la
mobilisation partielle bon presque
totale en fait en réalité ils emploient
les missiles comme ils l'ont fait le 24
février il menace les armes nucléaires
c'est leur dernière tentative de changer
le cours de cette guerre que le crâne
est en train de gagner n'est-ce pas sur
la ligne de front on voit depuis
plusieurs semaines des opérations avec
succès de l'armée crinienne est-ce que
vous la redoutez vous cette cette menace
succès nucléaire pardon qui a été sans
cesse agité par les russes depuis le
début de cette crise
on pense que bien sûr bien sûr monsieur
Poutine a perdu le lien avec la réalité
donc tout est possible mais franchement
on évolue les lire chancerelles de
l'emploi des armes nucléaires comme
comme assez peu élevé en fait pour
plusieurs raisons pour des raisons qu'il
était bien prévenu de gestes de
partenaires de l'Ukraine donc le geste
les choses à prendre les mesures à
prendre en fonction de cela et en plus
ça ressemble beaucoup plus en chantage
donc nous sommes déjà attaqués plusieurs
cibles même en Russie donc les
territoires que la Russie considère
comme russe comme un Crimée par exemple
même le pot le pont du crime etc mais le
nucléaire n'est pas utilisé donc on
s'oppose des questions est-ce que ça
relève plutôt plutôt du chantage et puis
de volonté désespéré d'effrayer les
occidentaux que de mentionner à chaque
moment cette menace nucléaire puisque
vous parlez des occidentaux les pays
membres du G7 se réunissent cet
après-midi en urgence autour de Wallonie
merzelinski par visio-conférence au-delà
d'un affichage de solidarité qui est
constant depuis le début de cette crise
qu'est-ce que peuvent proposer les 7
puissances aujourd'hui à l'Ukraine
qu'est-ce que vous en attendez vous
c'est très clair c'était Guy plusieurs
fois on entend plus d'armements en
termes de chars en termes de système
d'artillerie qui peuvent attendre les
objectifs
à distance supérieure à 100 km pour être
à l'égal avec la Russie qui peut elle
envoyer des missiles à 2000 km donc dans
les profondeurs du territoire ukrainien
bien sûr la défense de l'espace aérien
c'était demandé à plusieurs reprises
certains systèmes ont été promis par
l'Allemagne durant l'été et c'est
malheureusement que maintenant qui
commence à se précipiter un peu donc
c'est cette course contre le temps à
chaque fois l'Ukraine a toujours les
mêmes demandes au camp puis de l'Europe
ne pouvait faire face à la Russie et
puis tout seul avec les armements qu'on
a on a besoin des armements on a besoin
de système de protection aérienne
honorer les promesses non tenues aussi
si je vous suis bien il y a encore des
promesses qui ont été formulées hier
notamment celle de de Joe Biden de
fournir à volody merzelinski des
systèmes perfectionnés de défense
aériennes ça ce sont les mots on voit
souvent qu'il faut du temps avant que
des promesses se traduisent en acte
oui bah oui ça s'apprend toujours autant
sans comprendre mais parfois ça prend un
peu trop de temps tout simplement parce
que les missiles les Russes frappent la
population les civils bien sûr aussi les
militaires en crédit puis cette mois et
demi donc ça fait vraiment ça a donné
quand même un laps de temps suffisant
pour comprendre que sans cette aide on
pourra pas marcher les troupes craignées
dans des montraient leur capacité non
seulement de résister mais aussi de
faire des contre-offensives mais
justement il faut être solidaire dans le
sens que de se fixer un objectif très
clair là de fait militaire de la Russie
merci beaucoup Tatiana ogerkova merci
d'avoir été à